here South Korea's largest defense
company is testing a new batch of
weapons
The Wall Street Journal got a rare look
inside hanwar's facilities as it
constructs howitzer's destined for
Poland and submarines that could bolster
NATO's Arsenal in the future
that says South Korea is increasing its
arms sales at a rate faster than
anywhere else in the world
in just a five-year period it has grown
its defense export by 177 percent
although the U.S Russia and France have
considerably larger defense Industries
analysts say the pace at which South
Korea is expanding its output marks a
substantial shift for the future
so here's how the country is
transforming into a defense Giant and
what it means for the Western military
Alliance
workers inside this hanoir plant are
building dozens of self-propelled canine
howitzers is South Korea's largest
defense company they are playing a big
role in South Korea's arms exports
that's largely due to Poland a key NATO
member purchasing them as part of a 13.7
billion dollar arms deal
military analysts say the rapid speed
the workers here can build them is a
major selling point
process is completed in three stages
assembling the skeleton of the weapon
connecting the parts and then testing
its performance
although the company won't disclose
specific production times recent
deliveries have been prompt the first
shipment of canines arrived in Poland in
December just over three months after
the deal was signed
that's in contrast to other arms deals
in Europe that are still ongoing years
after the agreements were made
is a quick completion time is a major
part of its strategy to entice new
customers
literary analysts say South Korea is
able to build these systems faster than
some Western counterparts in part
because of Decades of escalating
Regional tensions
at the end of the Cold War military
powers in Europe began reducing their
capacity to produce Conventional Weapons
while the threat from North Korea LED
Seoul to ramp up its production
in the years since then South Korea has
mostly focused on developing traditional
Battlefield weapons so while countries
like the US have focused on creating
high-end weapons such as aircraft and
nuclear submarines South Korea has
focused on other weapons such as
artillery but now it's looking to export
more advanced Naval designs to the West
at this Handler Shipyard workers are
building vessels including the kss-3 the
company's newest submarine industry
analysts say it's one of the most
affordable pieces of its caliber in the
world Anwar is negotiating to sell the
diesel powered craft to Canada another
NATO member the company is trying to
keep costs and production time down by
using automated machines and producing
more components locally
um
the company plans to double its
production capacity for these systems by
2027.
military analysts say the designs could
help bolster nato in the future as
China's Navy which is the world's
largest continues to expand
traditionally NATO countries buy weapons
from other member states but South Korea
an ally of the alliance has been
fulfilling a niche for weapons that are
in demand due to the war in Ukraine
the U.S for example has also struggled
with supply shortages especially as it
continues to send lethal Aid to Ukraine
military analysts say supply chain
problems haven't been an issue for South
Korea partly because it's not sending
lethal weapons to Kiev
certainly we know that South Korea has
been facing pressure from the U.S and
also NATO to provide more than
non-lethal Aid to Ukraine because many
European countries and the US are
struggling in trying to backfill their
supply and they know that South Korea is
one of the most technologically advanced
countries with experience in exporting
their arms
South Korea's government expanding its
defense exports is a key policy
objective
president Yun Cirque is relying on
companies like hanoir to reach the goal
of becoming the fourth largest arms
exporter by 2027. the rapid growth is
not unsustainable According to some
military analysts who point to the
country's long tradition of manufactured
exports
that includes everything from Cars
phones and semiconductors to container
ships however as orders of these weapons
Stack Up defense analysts say soul may
be over promising how fast it can
complete them
being able to keep delivering them on
time will be key for its success
foreign